i was thinking to the joaquin phoenix  one you know when he gets in the fridge  what that was a totally different scene  where they're like he has all this  dialogue and stuff and he just gets in  the fridge and they're just like  no bro  he's improvised director  i didn't understand that scene i still  don't but i had a friend  who was like dude he was you know  everyone was so fired up in the joker's  like dude the scene where he gets in the  fridge that hit me so hard and i was  just like i didn't ask any follow-ups  but i was like the [ __ ] are you talking  he wants to be like it opened a jar of  pickles or something yeah that's what he  wants to be i guess it's like you want  to hide from the world or something like  that but it was like yeah i just thought  it was hot in his apartment yeah new  york in the summer dude it's broiling  true